I'm Captain Bob we got kalila Gilbert
hello
and the whitest dude on earth George
George do you know why the other night
he was on the phone I'm gonna say it and
he was getting off of a phone call and
he goes all right buddy rock and roll
that's what he said
rock and roll but to you he said no to a
friend he was on the phone some other
white dude that's how they talk to each
other because he doesn't know he was out
like it yeah I was I was kind of
listening in from around the corner see
you later bye a rock and roll but I'm
like rock n roll what do you think white
people mean when they say look I don't
know I don't know what that means
but it does they're up to no good when
you're rocking and rolling you're up to
no good
but um so that's one of your white
things that you do who wanted the white
yeah he says what the Freak what the
frick - why because the Battlestar
Galactica and they say what the Frick
really no Mormons to say what the Frick
he also says genuine oh that's fine
genuine English word it's fine yeah I
said genuine though yeah potato potato
potato potato come on
so I'm gonna tell you what it was but
this morning I had an audition for a TV
show and it's um the the I think that
the worst human experience is
auditioning mm-hmm I [ __ ] hate it I'm
not good at it it's torturous and
there's little things other people do in
there to sabotage you like what other
people auditioning yeah like if somebody
like if like a celebrity walks in right
he'll sign his name and then just kind
of stare at everyone in the room to let
them know that they're there it's like
[ __ ] you dude I'm not afraid
same [ __ ] in lower level stuff right
people are levels like I go in there
someone
signs up they read everyone's agent so
if you're the bigger one like CAA or
like WME yeah they start asking them
like Oh bro you're with WME too
Oh who's your agent and all the smaller
you know like reps we're all coming like
whoever does that whoever does that
needs to die yeah that's and I'll skin
him alive and I stick his body in Emma's
your honda piranha okay hey what's your
done yet okay I'm sorry
I'm not done yet okay or it's like today
I'm sitting in the lobby and some white
guy got Amen I follow you on Instagram I
said thank you but I go that's it you
don't talk to me anymore
he's what yeah I don't want to be here I
had to focus and he just kind of you
know he probably unfollowed me today
that's fine
because I feel like I'm not done okay
the long guy feel like you're gonna
switch to the top I'm not okay it's just
when I remember being in school or
before an exam and everyone would pile
up outside of the classroom or in the
hallways just it's it's just you
couldn't drown out people trying to
memorize last minute stuff and you would
[ __ ] up your own head yeah I would never
ever sit in that hallway I would always
be outside in my own space you know
trying to absorb last-minute information
but never when other people were there's
noise yeah it [ __ ] with your head in
your line of thought you know yeah you
know when you said about the signing in
yeah I don't even you can't read what I
say so that's it on illegible yeah yeah
I do three lines as my name right and
then my agency I put like a question
mark and then I don't do the time thing
you're not you put when you came in when
I don't do any of that you probably book
so many things they didn't know who to
contact I was hilarious he should be in
the matrix really they're the one that
called me and they don't know how they
called me that's true why the [ __ ] yeah
I'm not signing [ __ ] okay and then this
is the worst mr. Lee or Bob are you
ready and that walk to the coldest room
on planet Earth and as soon as you open
your mouth you know that you're gonna do
well or not it's the worst today
thankfully it was okay
nice but I just I hate it
I [ __ ] hate it and I don't sleep like
kalila has to say I just am I act I have
to run lines with him till about 7:00
the meanest person in the world to again
okay yeah I do yeah yeah I mean if I
look if this is not my understand if I
stumble on a line get it right you know
I you know why she has the words in
front of her right it's a sleepy I'm
happy everybody and then and then he
wakes up and then it's this is the worst
part about it he has to be up at 10:30
but not just him the whole house has to
be up for him he throws the script at me
and I'm in bed still half awake now I
have to run lines with him again did I
do that this morning though are you
didn't because you wanted to sleep a
little bit extra because I woke you up
yeah at 10:30 and I said Bobby get up
and he said nah nah I can't because
you're retired and you needed extra 30
minutes so I woke you up in 30 minutes
and you just went in but people aren't
coal tea in the room right because they
know who you are
no that's the world I hate it when I
hate it when date you can tell that
they're fans or whatever they know me
from other stuff and as soon as I start
doing you can tell that they're
disappointed no you can see in their
faces they don't know how to hide it you
know they kind of look at you with a
smile but then their eyes are like you
know and it's like but this morning
there was like a two-page kind of a
monologue right that you know I nailed
yeah so it won't be a good feeling when
you walk out the door especially when
you've nailed it does feel you know you
know it's not the feeling that you're
gonna get it it's a feeling that it's
it's like when you're at your soldier
and you did you served your Vietnam like
in the early 70s when they were flying
home and they were alive really that's
what it feels like release really yeah
that's what it is yeah and I I feel like
it is like Vietnam in there you audition
too don't you for that on Long Beach as
you could talk about the audition
process for that how to do
offer it was awful long for some with an
accent and sweats a lot we have so many
towels we don't know what to do yeah
it's the best thing I love that thing
yeah that is to be buried yeah I can't
believe you guys you could act
I could never act you have a teacher
right Thank You teacher I can't make eye
contact with people if I don't if I'm
not angry with you for I don't know if I
don't want to stress a point to you
directly I can't make eye contact with
you I think I have some type of like
Asperger's because if someone is let's
say telling me a story I have to keep
turning away like I have to keep
resetting myself because I cannot look
at them it's like overwhelming for me
but I only look at you directly if I'm
stressing a point or if I'm upset oh
jeez
like he knows it yeah otherwise I will
not I won't hold eye contact it makes me
uncomfortable not because I'm not
listening to you I just I feel
overwhelmed like I can't absorb all that
stimulus that is your face
[Music]